now I've been focusing a lot on the
government's plan this morning but what
about Labour's let's try and get to the
bottom of it we're joined from Salford
by the Charlotte Business Secretary
Rebecca long Bailey thank you for being
with us so two days until the prime
minister puts her plan to Parliament
labour have said that you want to vote
against it so let's get specific now
because this is really important
what would Therese may have to do what
assurances would you have to get from
Brussels for labour to support her
brexit deal well I don't think
assurances ever enough we've been
stating from you know the outset what
Labour would like to say from a deal
we're nowhere near that unfortunately
and unfortunately we're nowhere near
anybody else's red lines across
Parliament because we don't think that
Theresa May will have a majority on
Tuesday even from her own back Becher's
let alone the labour party but we do
think that a deal can be found within
Parliament that would be able to provide
a consensus not just within Parliament
but across Britain well the government's
had two years to deliver on that and
they found themselves to be incapable of
doing that which is why we're pushing
quite strongly in the event of Tereza
Mays deal falling that a general
election should be called and but what
I'm just struggling to work out is what
would need to change for labour to
accept the deal what is it that you want
well there's a number of issues the
customs union backstop is a key issue
we've been arguing for a permanent
customs union deal with the right for
Britain to have a say in future trade
deals what we have on the table is
nowhere near that provides for a customs
arrangement for Britain it's a
completely different arrangement for
Northern Ireland and it doesn't provide
any certainty whatsoever about what our
future customs arrangements are going to
be let alone what our overall agreement
with the EU is going to be the political
declaration itself is extremely
ambiguous it's deficient in a number of
areas workers rights security our future
trading relationship and I'm afraid
after two years that simply isn't good
enough we've been stating that we want a
deal that provides us with a strong
single market relationship we want to
have strong collaboration with the EU
and we want to write a floor under
existing rights and protections but not
just that we expect
UK government to keep up with
improvements in labor law with what
health and safety and environmental
rights we've been hearing for months on
the show that air labor want a general
election that's the policy that seems an
absolutely crystal clear so when are you
going to call a confidence motion in the
government will it be this week if
Theresa May loses that vote well we've
always said it's a case of when not if
and Jeremy's judging the situation day
by day well wait and see what happens on
Tuesday and we'll act you know at the
appropriate time but no no clarity on
when that's going to be it seems
extraordinary that you're so desperate
for an election and yet you can't give
any clarity and when you like who's cool
well of course the odds of us a table in
a vote of no-confidence increased
dramatically in the event that Teresa
Mae's deal Falls but ultimately the
decision rests with Jeremy and you know
it's up to him to determine when we do
you know put forward that vote of
no-confidence but it's certainly a case
of when knife okay above your paygrade
on the actual date of when it's called I
understand and now in the election that
labor so keen to get I'm just trying to
work out would you campaign for brexit
or against brexit well are correct
manifesto states that we respect the
result of the referendum and we want a
deal that puts our economy first now
ultimately of course when we go through
the next manifesto making process we
have those discussions within the Labor
Party but that is our position at
conference we agreed a wide-ranging
policy that stated that we wanted to
have a general election in the event
that Theresa Mays deal fell and that was
to avoid an old deal impasse but also to
ensure that we could put forward our
deal that would provide a consensus
across Parliament in the event that all
of that fails we wanted to keep all
options on the table because it's
critical to avoid a no deal situation
and okay so just trying to kind of
unpick you onto there it sounds like you
would be campaigning for brexit but a
different kind of deal negotiated now
just trying to kind of really get some
clarity on what labor wants to do last
week on the show Barry Gardner suggested
that actually what would happen is that
labor would have an election they then
renegotiate a deal and then put that
negotiated deal back to the British
people in a referendum is that party
policy that's not official party policy
at this stage I mean the policy that we
agreed at conference was to call a
general election try to secure the best
deal that we possibly can and in the
event that that's not possible or there
are any other issues we had all options
on the table and the specifics of the
policy that would go into our manifesto
you know we're a democratic party that
would be discussed at the appropriate
time when we were putting together the
manifesto but you know to be as clear as
I possibly can we've always said that we
respected the result of the referendum
we've always said that we wanted to
secure a good deal for Britain but in
the event that that seems impossible or
a No Deal situation seems to be hurtling
towards us we've been very clear within
the party that all options will remain
on the table but our priority has always
been making sure that we get that deal
okay and now this week we saw some
pretty horrific images really over MPs
being surrounded by protesters being
labeled Nazis they're being shouted at
and a Seabury the concert to MPs given
an interview in the last week where she
says that she won't even stand close to
the edge of the platform on the London
Underground cause she's worried about
people pushing her into the path of the
Train it's a frightening thing and then
paint a minute well it means certainly
in light of what happened to my
colleague Joe Cox a few years ago I
think it's brought home the reality of
the risks that are involved so members
of political parties but also all the
leading public figures and it's you know
it's not acceptable to be living under
that's the better fear but equally you
expect to be held to account as a
politician you expect your constituents
to tell you what they feel you expect to
be you know held to account for your own
actions as well but not in a way that
makes you feel intimidated or frightened
okay rebecca lynn bailey thank you very
much for being on the program today